marine le pen maintenant avec 89 députés
c'est la validation de sa stratégie de
normalisation un score historique qui
fait du rassemblement national le
premier parti d'opposition à l'assemblée
la députée du pas de calais réclament
donc la présidence de la très
stratégique commission des finances
emmanuel macron petit lui donner le
présent la république voulait affaiblir
les extrêmes c'est raté marine le pen
première opposante jean luc mélenchon ne
le supporte pas il propose donc à ses
alliés de constituer un groupe unique à
l'assemblée idées à peine évoqués et
déjà retoqué par les verts les
socialistes et les communistes la nuque
peut-elle survivre à ces divisions ce
sera l'un des enjeux des prochaines
semaines beaucoup de leçons à tirer vous
voyez beaucoup question à poser
également c'est parti pour 90 minutes de
sens public on commence par le rappel
voyez de cette majorité introuvable et
le résumé des faits majeurs de cette
journée avec cécile 6 à son arrivée à
l'assemblée gérald darmanin garde le
sourire le ministre de l'intérieur est
élu mais la majorité présidentielle et
subit une grosse défaite avec ses 240
saint-siège ensemble n'a pas obtenu de
majorité absolue il va devoir composer
avec d'autres politiques pour gouverner
nous travaillerons à construire une
majorité d'actions
il n'y a pas d'alternative à ce
rassemblement pour garantir à notre pays
la stabilité et conduire les réformes
nécessaires en ligne de mire les 61
députés et l'eire qui vous fermez la
porte cet après midi à tout pacte ou
coalitions nous conduirons comme nous
l'avons toujours faire une opposition
responsable c'est à dire en étant force
de proposition sur chacun des textes qui
seront proposés et et nous présenterons
une série de propositions sur les
différents sujets qui sont les sujets de
préoccupations des français face à la
majorité présidentielle la surprise
vient du r'n avec 89 sièges le parti de
marine le pen revendique la première
place d'opposants et promet de jouer son
rôle
meetic parce qu'eux mêmes à croire pour
faire ce qu'il veut non la réponse est
non clairement ce matin c'est non et
tant mieux c'est à dire la retraite à 65
ans je pense que c'est une réforme
enterrait ainsi que toute une série
d'autres mesures que souhaitait mettre
en place emmanuel macron et qui en
réalité étaient toxiques pour les
français jean luc mélenchon veut aussi
pesé comme principal opposant et propose
de transformer la nuque qui a obtenu 131
sièges en un seul groupe politique à
l'assemblée que chacun peut faire sa
rentrée des classes comme il veut à
l'assemblée nationale mais le signal qui
sera envoyé au pays c'est un bloc nous
sommes un bloc nous sommes une
alternative
une alternative est déclinée par ses
alliés socialistes écologistes et
communistes
emmanuel macron et la majorité
introuvable voilà le thème de notre tout
premier débat est finalement le le sujet
combien devoir de celle ci dessous pause
on arrange sentiment que le temps
médiatique le temps politique va de plus
en plus vite c'était le cas avec cette
journée particulièrement riche catherine
tricot directrice de la revue regards
bonsoir bienvenue catherine frédéric
potier expert associé à la fondation
jean jaurès auteurs de ce thriller
politique la menace 732 c'est publié aux
éditions de l'aube jean philippe dugoin
vous êtes directeur d'études à
l'institut de sondages ifop
bonjour bienvenue à vous et matthieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique
bienvenus mathieu 86 alors on va pas
commenter les résultats d'hier si
évidemment mais il s'est passé quand
même pas mal de choses aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous retenez de cette
journée mon 4 in one savoir qui va être
le leader de l'opposition et est-ce
qu'on est dans une situation qui est
nous nous conduit au chaos et donc je
pense que c'est un peu les deux
questions qui sont qui se joue moi je ne
crois pas que les élèves resteront sur
une position de fermeté de fermeture en
fait leur programme on a bien vu que
valérie pécresse n'a pas convaincu parce
qu'elle était trop proche au fond
idéologiquement et programmatiquement
d'emmanuel macron donc je ne vois pas
qu'ils mettent le pays dans une
situation de grave
difficultés et tension donc aujourd'hui
font monter les enchères et ils finiront
par trouver un accord avec avec emmanuel
macron reste qu'il faut construire des
oppositions parce que dans démocratie
faut des alternatives et donc là du coup
se joue la question de qui sera la
première force d'opposition mais c'est
vrai que marine le pen a fait une entrée
en force tracas senti hier donc la
gauche maintenant et au défi de
s'organiser face à cette situation jean
luc mélenchon fait une proposition c'est
peut-être pas la seule possible oui on
verra et ce sera l'un des thèmes de
notre débat forcément ferrique potier y
ait beaucoup de voix qui se sont
exprimées aujourd'hui sauf celle d'
emmanuel macron c'était peut-être trop
tôt mais évidemment tout le monde attend
ce qui va faire quelle peut être sa sa
stratégie sa réponse à ce qui est quand
même on peut retourner dans tous les
sens une très lourde défaite je me
disais en titre une lourde défaite un
tremblement de terre qui sera suivie
probant de petites répliques au
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale
d'abord au gouvernement parce qu'à un
remaniement qui se profile va falloir
remplacer les trois ministres matthew y
avait un certain nombre de portefeuilles
qui étaient laissés vacants sur le
logement sur le numérique les anciens
combattants et donc il y aura peut-être
un premier pas une première stratégie
consistera à élargir un tout petit peu
cette majorité peut-être en allant
débaucher des élus divers gauche divers
droite désunie mais il n'arrivera pas à
une quarantaine de sièges ou les 45 qui
vont me manquer donc après il aura deux
stratégies war 3 l'alliance des l'air
moche pas forcément convaincu par le
ralliement des leurs mais bon on verra
une autre stratégie qui est passé par le
49-3 mais on sait que c'est un usager
l'inité puis maintenant les limites y
maintenant limitée elle n'était pas à
l'époque michel rocard lors d'une
dernière situation civile de forme de
passage en force une fois par session et
puis la dernière stratégie c'est la
godille c'est à dire sur chaque texte et
se trouver des soutiens à gauche à
droite donc évidemment ça va pas être un
long fleuve tranquille jean philippe
duboux je commence par la question
désagréable ensuite je serai que sympa
avec vous il ya 89 députés du
rassemblement national et aucun institut
de sondage les les avait placés si haut
il y avait donc un vote cachée du du et
rennes nous on a eu sur ce plateau et
vous en soucier partie des représentants
des instituts qui était toujours prudent
sur les projections en sièges c'est
aussi une demande des médias de faire
des projections en ciel mais mais
comment vous expliquer le décalage quand
même or pour répondre très rapidement ce
que vous n'étiez pas d'entrée un vote
cacher est non aujourd'hui on ne se
cache plus de voter pour le rn même pas
encore reconquête d'eric zemmour le vote
cacher vu comment nous recueillons la
parole des individus c'est à dire par
internet sans enquêteurs sont personne
qui va vous jugé finalement fait que
leur cachet n'existe plus alors comment
on est la nôtre le décalage maintenant
les projections comme vouliez sont un
exercice extrêmement périlleux et puis
ensuite il ya un examen à faire de nous
mêmes et j'ai envie de la manière de
vous de dire de la manière dont on
conçoit la politique c'est à dire que en
tant qu asus sondage notre métier c'est
2 recenser tous les futurs possibles
finalement en matière politique c'est un
peu je faire une petite référence de
cinématographique mais c'est un peu
comme dans avengers quand le docteur
strange scan absolument toutes les tous
les futurs possibles et celui qui va
marcher c'est un peu notre métier là
dedans et donc des futurs possibles ou
le rassemblement national aurait pu
tutoyer les 100 sièges je vous dire très
franchement c'était envisagé est
envisagée mais eu égard au plafond de
verre que le rn a toujours connu une
égarons comportement jusqu'ici il
restait des bribes de forêt de front
républicain
cela fait donc que les hypothèses que
nous avons mis sur la table était un arn
au maximum à 50 peut-être un peu plus
terre vous n'avez pas osé croire à
l'hypothèse qui dit qu'ils mettaient fin
à quatre années tout à fait les le vote
des français d'hier a confirmé la mort
clinique du front républicain tout
simplement quand vous aviez des duels en
marche versus rassemblement national et
bien vous avez des électeurs de gauche
qui pour la plupart sont restés à la
maison quand vous aviez des duels nuque
versus et rennes vous avez des éléments
la majorité d'acteurs mars qui sont
restés à la maison donc le le front
républicain n'existe plus la campagne
finalement été très axé sur la nuque de
jean-luc mélenchon et la majorité
présidentielle eut finalement on a
inventé rennes qui s'est faufilé l'air
de rien et à qui on n'a jamais barrer la
route nir la campagne ni de religion
mathieu on va ouvrir avec vous un
chapitre plus spécifiques dans ce débat
dans ce premier débat consacré à
l'exécutif au président de la république
c'est pas simplement une défaite
électorale selon non c'est d'abord ce
n'est pas la première défaite électorale
qu'enregistre le président des
républicains des municipales régionales
où il a fait chou blanc en passant par
les européennes où il s'est fait en
rappelant de ravir la première place par
le rassemblement national le président a
déjà connu des échecs électoraux mais
ceux ci n'y prêtait guère à conséquence
pour la suite d'une certaine façon au
point que certains dans l'entourage du
chef de l'état parler de ces scrutins
défavorables comme des vulgaires
obstacle à enjamber on a enjambé le
scrutin et voilà ça portait pas à
conséquence d'une certaine façon cette
fois ci ça n'a rien à voir car la
déroute de dimanche échanges durablement
la donne pour le président de par sa
faculté à gouverner et à légiférer bien
sûr c'est pas impossible c'est même bien
plus difficile on vient de le dire avec
une majorité relative emmanuel macron
voulait imprimer sa marque sur
l'histoire en réformant la france comme
elle ne l'avait jamais été au cours de
son cinquième de son second quinquennat
en s'attaquant à des chantiers auquel
personne n'avait osé s'attaquer
ses ambitions sont là russell largement
contrarié depuis dimanche puis c'est
toute sa méthode toute sa façon de
présider c'est-à-dire de fonctionner qui
est aujourd'hui caduc un tout ne pourra
plus se décider d'en haut avec un
parlement qui ratifie derrière il va
devoir apprendre à consulter à négocier
bref à composer on ne sait pas si ça
fait partie de son tempérament c'est en
tout cas parce qu'il a montré depuis
cinq ans il l'avait promis toutefois
entre les deux tours faut le rappeler
cette fameuse nouvelle méthode mais on
attend encore de voir wifi là aussi il
ya l'humain il a perdu des femmes et des
hommes dans la bataille oui et non des
moindres dans son dispositif le
président des fidèles comme le président
de l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
le patron de démarcheurs à l'assemblée
christophe castaner son homologue du
modem patrick mignola bref des rouages
expérimenté à un moment où la macro n'y
en aurait bien besoin et il n'est pas
anodin d'une certaine façon que les
parrains des macros n'y ait que ce soit
edouard philippe ou françois bayrou ne
siège pas au parlement alors que le
pouvoir aurait besoin de figure
respectée sinon craintes au palais
bourbon les législatives ont aussi
envoyé au tapis des ministres qui
étaient dotées portefeuille qui étaient
pas des portefeuilles symbolique la mise
la santé c'est une priorité du
quinquennat la mise la transition
écologique c'est dans l'architecturé
gouvernementale un rouage essentiel là
encore mêmes pour ne rien arranger la
première ministre qu'il est désigné il
plus d'un mois par et sinon menacé pour
le moins très fragile certes elle s'est
fait réélire avec un score qui vient
maigrissime face à un inconnu d aiton de
22 ans et puis son profil il faut le
dire ne paraît pas le plus adéquat pour
justement concocter ses accords texte
par texte de majorité savoir un profil
très politique elisabeth bande ne s'en
cache pas c'est plutôt une femme de
dossiers une technicienne mais enfin le
plus embêtant c'est que le nouveau
rapport de forces issu du scrutin non
seulement modifié le paysage politique
mais aussi des facto l'adn du maquereau
nisme si jamais il y en avait un la
présence de la massive de la nuque
baisse lui ferme le couloir gauche et il
va le déporter mécaniquement sur la
droite bref le vieux clivage
droite-gauche réapparait malgré lui
contre son gré et puis du coup ça sonne
le glas du et en même temps et de tout
ce qui faisait l'originalité de son
positionne alors est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec avec cette idée je
commençais avoue catherine tricot vous
l'avais un peu évoqué tout à l'heure et
mal macron condamné à pencher vers sa
droite oui je pense que son discours
fadeur il à son électorat a basculé il a
rassemblé
autour de lui au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle un électorat
qui venait de la droite il a conservé
une partie de l'électorat n'a gauche
mais il a fait le plein son score
relativement élevé 28 % plus élevé
qu'attendu et le faible score de valérie
pécresse venait de 7,2 finalement cette
confusion des identités politiques entre
son programme son identité je dirais son
son adn culturel général five et du
monde de l'entreprise et du monde du
management de promises laissent etc et
tout ça ça a parlé à la droite et je
pense moi que la godille ne suffira pas
dans une période où quand même il ya des
idées des périls difficile dans notre
pays avec l'inflation les difficultés
sur l'
economic qui qui pointe et donc je ne
crois pas qu'on va s'installer dans un
système à la gaude il va falloir trouver
une forme de stabilité et on va rappeler
là lr est leur responsabilité à mon avis
un peu dans ce débat si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec potier pourquoi vous y
croyez pas un ralliement il a parce que
la ligne pour l'instant elle n'est pas
de ce côté là elle est l epa trek au
pays se trouve à dire la ligne je crois
que catherine a raison sur l'homo taissy
d'idées on voit bien qu'à une famille où
deux familles politiques qui peuvent se
parler et qui ont beaucoup d'atomes
crochus la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est quel est l'intérêt des élus et
l'air on a bien vu aurélien pradié une
des jeunes figures du parti des
républicains fermé la porte dès dimanche
soir une forme de ralliement on a bien
vu aussi rachida dati se positionner en
vue en perspective des élections
municipales 2026 donc moi je me demande
quel serait l'intérêt de ces élus et
leur avenir faire ce rôle de force
d'appoint on peut avoir des débauchages
individuels pour devenir secrétaire
d'état ministres etc une adhésion en
bloc d'une soixantaine de députés dont
certains sont quand même très marqué à
droite je pense at your type avant moi
j'y crois pas mais je crois qu'on est
dans un moment de mouvement politique où
tout bouge les plaques tectoniques
beaucoup et très vite mais s'efforce
d'annoncer au pea - sur moi mon
hypothèse à moi c'est que c'est une op à
ses adhérents fait compte tenu de la
fragilité de la
l'ensemble nom de ensemble c'est qu'en
fait ils ont quand même à l'intérieur
deux ensembles ya deux forces de droite
déjà installés le modem et horizons qui
sont quand même deux hommes politiques
de droite et y aller l air et moi je la
suite de l'histoire c'est eux qui ont
les clés et ils font de vous dites c'est
l'air qui fait alors en général dans le
monde économique celle inverse un cessez
le feu
vers quel serait l'intérêt de l air de
rester dans un groupe de soixante
députés se disant par je ne sais quel
hasard au miracle de la vie politique je
pourrais arriver en tête à la
présidentielle en 2000 en 2027 alors que
nerfs siège alors il va y avoir un
conflit de ligne et certains pourront
prôné l'union des droites et est plutôt
un accord avec leurs ascendants
nationale le vieux rêve d'eric zemmour
que pourrait hâter relais marine le pen
et quelques sioniste confirmé mais de
l'autre côté vous avez un grand paquebot
vide dont le capitaine ne se
représentera pas en 2027 avec toute une
partie de l'appareil qui est un peu
aujourd'hui dans les cordes des jeunes
lisaient des figures de cette majorité
qui ne figurent pas l'assemblée tenté
loupé à sa serai là ça se vaut pour pour
l'instant mais c'est peut-être le début
d'une négociation on avait dire ce que
vous en pensez pour l'instant le premier
mot qui vient quant à christian jacob
l'encore président pour quelques mois du
parti l air les républicains il sort
d'un comité stratégique si je ne me
trompe pas et le premier os qui vient
c'est quand même le mot opposition
écoute position très claire nous sommes
dans l'opposition
dans l'opposition au gouvernement et à
une manuelle macron nous avons combattu
pendant ces élections législatives et
nous resterons bien évidemment sur cette
ligne donc il n'est pas question ni de
pacte ni des coalitions ni quelques
accords de quelque nature que ce soit en
revanche nous conduirons comme nous
l'avons toujours faire une opposition
responsable c'est à dire en étant force
de proposition sur chacun des textes qui
seront proposés bon ben on pourra
ressortir ses c'est cette réaction de
christian jacob dans quelques semaines
on verra bien ce que vous y croyez ou
l'hypothèse on va dire croissandeau
tricot vu ce qui a été exposé les
républicains auraient tort de se priver
de partir à l'abordage du vaisseau
fantôme parce que c'est ce que vous
écriviez ils auraient bien tort mais ça
suppose si cette manoeuvre doit être
fait et réussir au moins en partie ça
suppose de l'accord du patron du
vaisseau fantôme qui est emmanuel macron
or
puis on a constaté l'absence de réaction
dans marche aujourd'hui hubert ben super
de silence si on se réfère à ce qui a
été dit hier par elisabeth board ce
qu'on a vu c'est en dépit de la débâcle
en dépit de la bérézina c'est une
flexibilité totale
de l'exécutif c'est à dire qu'aucune
main a été tendue alors que la majorité
plus affaiblie que jamais enfin dans
l'histoire de la vème république la
majorité plus affaiblie que jamais mais
aucune main tendue au coq une esquisse
de compromis de tentes et de composition
c'est non nous restons droits dans nos
bottes et nous invitons alors que nous
sommes affaiblis nous invitons les
autres à se rallier à nous il il y a
quelque chose de du déni l'un est donc
pour le moment même si on est au début
des enchères et il est normal d'affiché
exact chacun essaie ça c'est une négo
qui des négociations des arts annonce
qui démarre c'est ce que vous nous dites
on est dans les postures et l air tout à
fait raison de son point de vue on verra
ce que donne l'histoire et s'ils font un
deal ou pas et quand même un camp mais
ils ont tout intérêt d'errements il n'en
est pas question ils pourront dire après
finalement nous en ferons preuve de
responsabilité c'est comme ça que ça se
passe généralement et et puis ils y
feront dans le ring shopping list ses
larges ou le demanderont qui sait
pourquoi pas matignon pourquoi pas des
ministres clés pourquoi pas lors de
certains ministres qui disent à
l'unisson des finances parce que s'ils
sont dans l'opposition si aujourd'hui
sont dans l'opposition ils peuvent
obtenir la commission des finances puis
puis basculer dans un accord où ira bien
la dernière alors oui mais ça non mais
ça veut dire que la commune il faudrait
que la nuque il faut il suffit qu'ils
disent qu'ils sont dans l'opposition
pour pouvoir prétendre jouer mais c'est
un voyou ce prix c'est un vote sur les
finitions donc il faudrait que les
représentants de la nulle pour la banque
c'est tout non non on a un peu de mal à
la clé je rebondis sur ce que vous
disiez sur le côté un peu des nues tient
à écouter
stanislas
guérini c'était ce matin sur rtl on va
mettre les propositions du programme
présentiel sur la table et ce seront ces
propositions qui seront discutés quand
il s'agira de rein l'excellent et
retraite sur l'inflation quand il
s'agira d'augmenter le point d'indicé
pour les fonctionnaires
quand il s'agira de protéger nos
concitoyens pour bloquer les prix de
l'énergie elle se constitue pas cette
majorité avec des étiquettes politiques
elle se constitue autour de textes
intérêt général et donc nous parlons là
de mesures très concrètes et c'est avec
cette philosophie que nous souhaitons
avancer oui une information que isabelle
passé la rédactrice en chef de
l'émission vient de me souffler dans ce
magnifique outil qu'on appelle
l'oreillette le conseil des ministres
qui étaient prévues demain et repoussé
c'est bien ça l'information isabelle
hains il était prévu demain et il est
repoussé ferrique petit sks que vous
employez le même terme que j'enfile
dubrulle est ce qu'il ya un déni pour
l'instant façon choc peut-être due aux
résultats ça arrive aussi dans nos vies
quand on vit un drame il ya une espèce
de sidération est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il ya un déni je crois qu'il ya une
forme de traumatismes traumatisme
l'évidence devant le choc des résultats
et puis dès les fêtes après il ya
peut-être aussi une part de stratégie
alors la stratégie d'évitement a pas été
une bonne idée pendant la campagne mais
là je sens se deviner quand même forme
de deux stratégies d'évitement au
parlement peut-être qu'en creux il ya
l'idée que et bien puisqu'on n'a pas de
majorité on va moins légiférer on va
moins déposé texte de loi on va les
concentrer sur quelques grands textes
sur lesquels ce sera difficile de voter
contre notamment en matière économique
de soutien au pouvoir d'achat et puis
peut-être qu'il y aura quelques textes
qui seront mis à l'agenda au contraire
pour diviser la gauche je pense les
textes peut-être sur la transition
énergétique sur la sécurité sur la
sécurité ou l'aller les dissensions
entre les différentes familles de gauche
peuvent ressurgir donc la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il aura peut-être moins de
texte la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
pour le débat démocratique c'est pas sûr
que c'est une bonne chose de jouer
l'idiot la main parce que quand on a 16
guérini qui libère va arriver avec nos
nos propositions du programme
présidentiel ce que vous êtes d'accord
banon ils sont pas d'accord puisqu'ils
sont présentés contre et on a obtenu un
résultat qu'on sait à la mer
l'opposition et notamment la france a
soumis ce débat oui on est prêt à voter
si jamais il ya le smic à 1500 euros si
jamais le blocage des prix bas non ça
marchera pas comme ça on sait bien à doc
là tout le monde se regarde en chiens de
faïence c'est pas comme ça que ça
marchera ça c'est une stratégie du
pourrissement s'est montré que c'est un
blocage et qui à terme je n'ai pas tout
de suite pas dans un mois pas dans deux
mois mais au bout d'un an par exemple
pourrait conduire le président de
république à dire c'est plus possible
regardez j'ai fait la preuve par
l'absurde auprès des français que nous
étions dans une forme de blocage
politique et institutionnelle donc j'en
appelle à la dissolution oui il ya ya ya
vous n'êtes pas constitutionnalisme
emmanuel macron il peut dissoudre
quand il veut et un délai ya également
ces douze mois entre deux dissolution
mais un petit débat entre conscience
pour savoir si l'élection menée à son
terme ce quelqu'un e de diers et déjà
enfin ouvre cette période ou pas c'est
pas évident bon en tout cas on peut
imaginer qu'il se passera du temps parce
que il faut et je rejoins ce que dit
mathieu catherine tricot pour proposer
aux français une dissolution il faut
d'abord faire la démonstration du
blocage et de plusieurs blocages non non
moi je crois pas que ce soit si je dis
pas c'est pas le plan b mais je pense
que le plan a c'est pas la dissolution
c'est pas d'aller vers une crise de
régime avec une impossibilité de
gouverner etc je pense quand même qu'il
ya des enjeux aujourd'hui qui enfin dans
lequel se joue à la fois la vie des
français la place de la france dans
l'europe là la réponse face aux enjeux
majeurs que l'on connaît enfin dont on
vient de parler à l'instant climatiques
économiques etc je pense qu'il ya quand
même là ils vont essayer de trouver une
façon dont ils jouent pas simplement
d'abord dépassés ils ont ils pensent
porter une politique et vont essayer de
la mettre en oeuvre et vont essayer de
trouver des alliés pour faire ça là je
pense qu'ils gagnent du temps entre hier
soir et ce matin je comprends que ça
flotte un peu que madame bornes hier
soir était inflexible parce qu'elle
n'avait pas grand chose à dire on peut
le comprendre ça veut pas dire que ça
sera ça la réponse pour le mois qui
vient on parlait de dissolution si
dissolution il doit y avoir ces blocages
qui doit y avoir mais blocage imputable
à qui c'est à dire que si fin pour
qu'une dissolution vaille le coup il
faut que le blocage que la majorité
puisse montrer clairement que le blocage
est dû à l'opposition si l inverse
l'opinion pense que le blocage est dû à
l'entêtement de la majorité la
dissolution devra que l'effet de toute
élection partielle collection refaite cr
confirmer ce qui a été fait avant donc
voilà c'est un genre c'est un jeu
dangereux ce sera un jeu dangereux et
que sa dissolution et ça implique un
travail d'opinion et de mise en scène de
l'affrontement politique pas simple mais
est ce qu'on peut imaginer des potiers
des majorités j'allais dire alternative
ou de circonstances c'est à dire sur un
texte on va aller chercher des députés
je vais dire écologistes et où
socialistes pour faire passer la loi sur
l'urgence écologique puis à linverse
aller chercher une majorité plus à
droite sur un autre texte sécurité je
caricature mais est ce qu'on peut
imaginer ça ah oui c'est tout à fait
possible dans le texte qui est déjà
sur le bureau de l'assemblée sur la
sécurité qui a été porté par gérald
darmanin ça sera très difficile pour les
députés l'air de ne pas le voter
al'inverse un texte qui porterait sur le
développement durable alors peut-être
que les écologistes trouveront qui va
pas assez loin mais ça sera difficile
aussi de voter contre donc bon il ya la
part des convictions et puis après il ya
le jeu de rôles parlementaires aussi
mais c'est possible avec intel gap parce
que là il manque il manque 40 4 des 6 et
pour atteindre les fatidiques 189 quand
même avec des abstentions par groupe ça
peut passer moi je pense que ça marche
sur des petites affaires on peut gagner
un peu de temps encore une fois comme ça
mais enfin bon quand il s'agit de
traiter la question des retraites de
l'éducation nationale de l'hôpital le
budget de la france etc etc tout ça on
peut pas faire ça peut pas être encore
une fois pour trois mois jusqu'en
septembre ça peut le faire mais ça peut
pas être un mode de gouvernement de
gouvernance pour la france durable il ya
un projet de loi de finances
rectificative
pour cet été je vois mal l'opposition
prêté ces voies prêté son concours à la
majorité pour l'adopter le problème de
ces passerelles c'est qu'on a quand même
des blocs qui sont assez étanche le
rassemblement national d'à côté qui est
décidé à ne pas faire de cadeau et c'est
pas son enjeu l'enjeu du rassemblement
national pour ce pour cette législature
cette respectabilité ce notabilisé faire
la preuve qu'il peut être une
alternative enfin crédible de l'eau du
côté de la nuque baisse j'ai peine à
imaginer que les insoumis accepte ben
oui c'est une bonne idée où les
écologistes et pourquoi pas aux tests
sur le développement durable en on a
bien vu dans l'est dans les salles au
climat les écologistes étaient sur ce
n'est pas assez enfin il y avait
à l'assemblée donc c'était compliqué
mais gère dans le discours en tout cas
c'est le projet de loi était nulle et
c'était présent d'une action climatique
on va voir si moi je le dis souvent mais
est-ce qu'à une majorité de playmobil
telle qu'on avait caricaturé est décrite
lors du précédent quinquennat va
succéder une opposition playmobil qui
votera non quelle que soit la question
parce qu'elle a été proposée par
emmanuel macron et c'est là où est ce
que chacun sera capable une forme de
dépassement ou est ce que chacun sera
campé sur ses positions nous dit tel est
le cas le plus le blocage paraît quand
même assez inévitable sauf alliance
évidemment et keller gros plan dans les
minutes qui suivent dans ce débat sur
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale c'est l'une des informations
importantes de cette journée on a
entendu un extrait dans le sujet
d'ouverture de ce journal jean luc
mélenchon qui appelle à la formation
d'un groupe unique pour la nuit par
l'assemblée il ne veut pas laisser aux
arènes le statut de premier parti
d'opposition
je crois que nous devons
être et rester une alternative unis
autrement dit la nuque devrait se
constituer comme un seul groupe au
parlement de manière à ce que sans
aucune discussion possible il soit
établi qui
mène l'opposition dans le pays et que
dès lors nous soyons prêts à tout moment
y compris à de nouvelles élections
a présenté la candidature de l'année
pour
catherine tricot est un peu d'arrière
pensées politiques derrière cette
déclaration quand même oui il veut faire
mettre tout le monde dans la même dans
le même groupe et puis ont gardé le
contrôle puisque quand même à
l'intérieur de l'aide de la gauche c'est
quand même là et fille qui a la part du
lion c'est lui qui a donné un peu le la
dans toutes les négociations et la
répartie l'imposé la répartition entre
les circonscriptions il a quand même
donné le cadre de l'accord même le nom
on va dire un nouvelle union populaire
écologique et citoyenne ça reprend le
nom la campagne mélangeant une idée
quand même le leader vraiment de ça et
là je pense qu'il veut il propose un pas
de plus ce que je trouve là c'est un
piège politique ou ses alliés
a été retoqué
presque 100 députés de l air et on ne
les a pas entendus comme première force
politique d'opposition à emmanuel macron
c'était bien la france a soumis qu avec
ses 17 députés qui ont fait le plus de
travail d'opposition donc le d'être le
premier groupe d'opposition ça d'abord
un ils ont prévu de se coordonner il n'y
a pas de raison qu'il ne le fasse pas et
ensuite ils vont devoir montrer leur
capacité d'innovation de proposition et
de résistance pour pouvoir mais ça ne se
joue pas sur 7 sur cette alliance
l'acquis pas qu'il ne peut pas passer
les partis de gauche sont historiquement
sont divers on ne voit pas comment ils
peuvent être tous réunis dans la même
maison comme ça du jour au lendemain et
puis frais et petit j'y reviens le choix
il est impossible pour ses alliés par
lui se pose en rassembleur très bien
mais soit ils disent banon on veut pas
ils l'ont dit très vite donc sont les
diviseurs soit il se sait venez-vous
dissoudre dans dans la nuée et perdent
un peu un peu beaucoup de votre identité
c'est quand même le choix possible est
ce que ça que ça ressent comme un gros
gros piège presque trop gros pour elle
et c'est un peu trop gros pour être
vraiment crédible d'autant plus que je
vois pas quel est l'intérêt ni au ps ni
chez les écologistes ni aux parties
communes français d'accepter cette
proposition parce qu'un groupe ça donne
du temps de parole ça donne des experts
ça donne du droit d'interpellation du
gouvernement et donc je comprends que
cette proposition était retoqué tout de
suite par valérie rabault au nom des
socialistes et par d'autres et
d'ailleurs on a on a vu le nombre de
députés par para group est une salve de
cbs c'est
parce que il a deux déceptions ce matin
il a pas réussi l'objectif qu'il a vendu
à son électorat lisez-moi matignon non
bah il peut pas y aller parce qu'il est
même très loin du compte et le deuxième
la deuxième déception mais c'est que la
france est soumise il pensait que ça
serait le premier parti d'opposition
représenté à l'assemblée nationale il se
fait doubler par par le rassemblement
national donc du coup une tentative
autour d'un troisième tour un peu
interne de récupérer la mise est de se
dire nous sommes la première
la première force parce que pourquoi
c'est pour des questions de prestige et
rire de poids politique mais aussi de
moyens de postes il ya la fameuse
commission des finales présidence de la
commission des finances qui est en jeu
qui est un poste honorifique et
politique de poids au parlement c'était
solide en la commission la plus
respectée dans le temps et sont et son
président a accès à tout un nombre de
données qu'elles soient confidentielles
ou non sur l'état de l'économie
française mais aussi sur la fiscalité
sur les choses comme ça donc c'est un
poste stratégique et jean luc mélenchon
qui est un fin politique veut pas que ce
soit leur assemblée nationale qui kills
qui ramasse la mise donc il propose cet
alliage un peu de dernier moment pour
pour tenter de s'imposer comme comme une
seule force unique mais oui mais la
logique pour le parti socialiste
europe écologie verts vous partie
commises d'intégrer la nuque c'était de
garder la possibilité d'avoir chacun un
groupe à l'assemblée enfin vous pas
obligé oublier l'objectif initial oui
oui alors il ya l'objectif initial des
partis mais on peut aussi se dire que
quand même cette gauche unie elle est
quand même devant une difficulté
profonde et structurelle qui va lui
demander de l'invention à dire que ça ne
suffira pas de rassembler tout le monde
sous la même étiquette pour répondre à
la question qui est posée notamment par
le fait que les jeunes ne sont pas venus
voter et que dans les catégories
populaires on a voté pour le front
national donc cette réponse est question
n'a qui est devant l'ensemble des forces
de gauche il va falloir de la diversité
de la réactivité de l'innovation des
audaces etc et je ne crois pas moins
qu'une seule réponse soit possible je
pense que la gauche a besoin de cette
diversité est d'ailleurs tout le monde y
est allé aussi pour cette raison la wii
est d'une certaine façon fabien roussel
le candidat communiste à la
présidentielle avait répondu par avance
à jean luc mélenchon puisque c'était
hier sur france 3 à écouter ce que dit
celui qui a été élu député du nord j'ai
déjà
dit pendant la campagne que j'avais des
différences et que je ne me retrouvais
pas dans des propos qui pouvaient être
tenus notamment au nom de cette alliance
parce que je le sens bien chez moi là
donc dans cette france rurale dans la
campagne qu'il y a des propos qui
heurtent les français et qui ne sont pas
compris il faut que justement on arrive
à rassembler l'ensemble des français
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens qu'ils
soient de la campagne ou des grandes
agglomérations que l'on arrive à parler
à toute la france aurait rejoint voit
bien que l'alliance elle ne parle qu'à
une partie de la france à celle des
grandes villes et pas à celle de la
ruralité jean-phi bible la demande
d'unité elle était
forte très forte chez les électeurs de
gauche est-ce que les sympathisants
socialistes ouvert on pour autant envie
je reviens à la proposition de jean luc
mélenchon de ce fonds ou dans 1 dans un
parti unique quoi ou alors là en
l'occurrence dans un groupe unique non
très simplement parce qu'il ya encore
des gens qui se définissent comme proche
idéologiquement du ps d'europe écologie
les verts du parti communiste est par
ailleurs la france insoumise donc au
sein du peuple de gauche comment comme
on l'appelle il y à des sensibilités
différentes elles existent donc que la
nuque finalement se divise en chapelle
au sein de l'assemblée nationale ne
serait que logique par rapport à cette
identification l'électorat maintenant il
ya ce qu'on se sent comme identité et à
ce qu'on veut faire le registre de
l'action morts les électeurs de gauche
ont été vaccinées par les différents
scrutins précédents et notamment par la
présidentielle ont tapé leurs voeux une
union qui s'est concrétisée lancé
législatives 5 m2 le premier fait ces
législatives il ya lieu afin vote c'est
cette union
est aujourd'hui finalement l'habileté
jean luc mélenchon en mettant ses
partenaires dont le fait accompli en
lançant ce ballon d'essai immédiatement
retoquée et bien c'est faire passer ses
collègues fins et ses partenaires aux
yeux de l'électorat pour des fins pour
les pour les réviseurs et pour les
diviseurs parce que le les électeurs de
gauche tous les ans par an pendant en
particulier ceux qui fait pas forcément
au fait d'eux des rouages de l'assemblée
nationale de la constitution des groupes
des moyens que ça débloque etc vous êtes
électeur de gauche vous souhaitez à
mener la gauche en nombre à l'assemblée
et le lendemain de leur arrivée et
commencent déjà à se crêper le chignon
c'est extrêmement frustrant donc il ya
qu un terrier il ya un espoir fort chez
la gauche même si mélenchon n'a pas été
envoyé à matignon il ya un sport très
fort qu'il ne s'agirait pas de décevoir
mathieu sk pas aussi une petite question
de 2,2 de forme les alliés des filles
qui veulent qu'ils aient un peu de
démocratie interne ces brosses de la
nuque quand on négocie avec des
partenaires des alliés des amis des
camarades on le fait pas par caméras
interposées généralement c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe j'ai on se réunit on
discute et puis ensuite on sort avec un
communiqué en tout cas c'est comme ça
que ça se passait dans le temps de
l'histoire de la gauche quand on le fait
par caméras interposées c'est qu'on
engage un rapport de force avec comprend
l'opinion publique à témoin et qu'on
cherche exactement à faire ce que
j'écrirai jean philippe du roule c'est à
dire c'est la faute des autres ces
malades viennent donc voilà et c'est
refiler le mistigri de la défaite entre
guillemets ou de l'incapacité de la
france est soumise à réclamer ce poste
par exemple de la présence commission
des finances mais aussi autre chose en
refilant le mistigri alors on en
reparlera de cette logique là quand on
parle à deux motions de censure tout à
l'heure dans notre second débat mais je
voudrais qu'on consacre la halle à la
fin de cette première partie au
rassemblement national je le disais en
titre percée historique le parking
marine le pen remporté 89 sièges steve
jourdain vous devez être juste là en
coulisses
bonsoir steve bienvenue à vous sur le
plateau de sens public qu'est ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça va changer qu'est ce
que ça change pour la formation
d'extrême droite ou ou presque thomas où
vous l'avez dit 89 députés crainte 89
députés c'est trois fois plus qu'en 1986
date à laquelle le front national avait
obtenu pour la première fois un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale c'était à l'époque
où scrutin proportionnel alors qu'est-ce
qu'ils se changent aujourd'hui bien
marine le pen va pouvoir créer un groupe
parlementaire il faut 15 députés pour en
former un pas de problème pour le rn qui
en rafle donc 89 le parti devrait même
s'imposer devrait même s'imposer comme
le principal groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale et ça ça change
beaucoup de chose pour marine le pen
écoutez nous demanderons tout ce à quoi
nous avons droit tout ce qui aurait été
accordée au premier groupe d'opposition
à l'assemblée nationale donc la
présidence de la commission des finances
bien sûr et une présence bien sûr parce
que le groupe que nous avons qui encore
une fois le premier groupe d'opposition
de l'assemblée ne transigera sur aucun
des moyens qui lui est accordée par la
tradition ou par les règles
républicaines
pour pouvoir défendre les français et
puis steve concrètement quelles sont les
retombées de cette réussite électorale
pour leur lumière et des paillettes dans
l'avis de marine le pen dans les mois
qui viennent le rnb être sous le feu des
projecteurs il va pouvoir imposer ses
thèmes à l'assemblée nationale dans les
médias quand vous avez un groupe de 89
députés à l'assemblée nationale vous
pouvez prétendre à l'un des six postes
de vice-présidents de la somme est sain
mais nationale ou à l'un des trois
postes de questeur vous pouvez demander
de siéger dans les commissions
permanentes ce qui permet d'avoir son
mot à dire sur les textes examinés dans
l'hémicycle et justement mathieu en
parlais tout à l'heure en ce qui
concerne ces commissions tout le monde
lorgne actuellement et bien sûr la très
stratégique présidence de la commission
des finances et enfin avec un groupe
parlementaire vous participez à la
conférence des présidents c'est l'organe
suprême qui organisent la vie de
l'assemblée nationale et les travaux
parlementaires et donc les représentants
du rassemblement national seront plus
visibles et on va plus les entendre au
site oui ces images et sons pour marine
le pen avec ses 89 députés le
rassemblement national aura un temps de
parole dédié ça veut dire plus de temps
pour exprimer ses positions par exemple
pendant les questions au gouvernement ou
encore pendant l'examen des textes de
loi il pourra aussi bénéficier de ce
qu'on appelle un droit de tirage c'est à
dire qu'une fois par session il pourra
demander la création d'une commission
denquête une mission d'information sur
le sujet de son choix et enfin le
rassemblement national pourra une fois
par mois fixer l'ordre du jour dans
l'hémicycle c'est à dire qu'il pourra
déterminer les sujets qui sont abordés
lors d'une séance on a en tête par
exemple un texte de loi sur la lutte
contre l'islamisme texte que marine le
pen avait considéré comme la priorité
numéro un de la mandature à venir bref
c'est une élite mal le rn va jouer un
rôle très important au parlement dans
les mois et années qui viennent c'est
l'un des trains des grands enseignements
de ce second tour merci beaucoup style
jourdain ferry potier marine le pen qui
prend donc la prendre la présidence de
ce groupe et rennes à l'assemblée
voilà on c'est une étape supplémentaire
mais majeur quand il faut employer un
autre adjectif majeur crucial dans la
stratégie de banalisation on y est on y
est quoi on y est parce que d'abord
c'est la fin d'une forme de plafond de
verre avant le front national faisait
beaucoup de voix dans le quart nord-est
dans le quart sud-est avec quelques élus
là il ya des élus en gironde il ya des
élus dans leur il ya un carton plein
dans les pyrénées orientales dans l'aude
et donc on a un front national assemblée
nationale désormais qui a implanté dans
de très nombreux endroits et qui n'est
plus que sur quelques bastions et à cela
il faut ajouter dans les avantages
d'avoir un nombre de députés importance
c'est un avantage financier bien sûr a
été dit mais en termes de financement
public je crois que le montant sera à
peu près 10 millions d'euros par an pour
l'assemblée nationale donc ça va pouvoir
aider grandement leur assemblée
nationale qui avait quelques dettes à
régler avec évidemment c'est tout sauf
négligeable jean-philippe dubrulle c'est
intéressant de comparer 2017 et 2022
quand on voit les duels la capacité du
rassemblement national à remporter des
duels ça tout à fait on le voit à
l'échelle de l'assemblée donc 89 députés
qui débarque contre beaucoup moins
avancé déjà visibles voilà mais si on se
penche sur ces duels en marche contre le
rassemblement national on peut faire le
compte la comparaison avec 2010 est je
rappelle qu'à de maquereaux avait dit
voter pour moi pour que plus jamais les
extrêmes ne montent en 2017 il y avait
environ 100 duel de second tour en
marche contre le rassemblement national
sur une centaine le front national
d'alors en a gagné 7,7 sur cent cette
année hier sur une centaine de duels
également 107 pour être précis 50 50 au
temps gagné par en marche autant gagnée
par le rassemblement national donc c'est
bien la preuve que 1 emmanuel macron a
failli à son engagement de lui incarner
le barrage ou au vote d'extrême droite
mais c'est aussi la preuve que c'est un
parti quand vous disiez qui s'est
normalisée tout simplement c'est un
parti comme un autre ressort
parfaitement représenté à l'assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs paul sébile de
l'ifop a fait cet après midi une
projection des résultats du vote du
second tour qu'est ce que ça donnerait
en vote proportionnel pur c'est
quasiment la même chose qu'eux seront là
édifiante le scrutin uninominal à deux
tours n'est n'est plus un barrage pour
l'extrême droite c'est on a quasiment
une proportionnelle en fait l'assemblée
d'aujourd'hui comme si elle est que
c'est comme si elle avait été élue à la
proportionnelle le front républicain
catherine tricot c'est un mot du passé
bah écoutez là en tout cas il a
clairement explosé je pense qu'il
explose sous l'action de deux éléments
c'est à dire la volonté de 60% des
français qui le disait dans les sondages
de battre mâcon c'est à dire de ne vois
là et donc du coup ils ont décidé que
n'importe quel bulletin pouvait faire la
faire donc le rn part dans l'arène la
république en marche face à alan eu pour
face au front national il était en
difficulté parce qu'il y avait la
volonté de battre mais la deuxième chose
c'est quand même le fruit de cette
campagne dans lequel on a mis la nuque
comme étant le grand danger que courait
la france du coup ça a laissé le front
national avancer tranquillement ça à
mobiliser l'électorat de droite qui
s'est dit il faut surtout pas que la
nuque et la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et que donc en traçant cette
égalité entre deux dangers entre
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite et
en disant que finalement le danger
d'extrême gauche était le plus pressant
on a mobilisé su remobiliser la droite
et ça n'a pas beaucoup mobilisé par
contre l'électorat jeune et populaire en
faveur de la nuque saleilles potier on
est là aussi pour tirer les
enseignements de cette première journée
post scrutin marine le pen elle est sur
un registre et ça rejoint ce que des
auteurs très républicain c'est vraiment
je disais le premier mot qui vient à la
bouche de christian jacot ces
oppositions marine le pen ces
républiques quoi ah oui elle est dans
l'extrême banalisation cerqual explique
leur asthme et cela est un parti comme
les autres qui a droit d'ailleurs c'est
la pure vérité en droit parlementaire
aux mêmes droits que les autres groupes
parlementaires et donc elle vient pas
pour faire la révolution à l'assemblée
nationale eh bien pour s'y installer et
prendre date pour l'avenir qu'est-ce que
ça ouvre comme perspectives pour les
prochains scrutins
jean philippe duboux là évidemment je
vais pas vous demander de me demande ma
non c'est ce que ce que son nom mais on
a dit plafond de verre brisé on 10 fin
du front républicain voilà si on si on
prend la logique la prochaine étape
c'est quoi c'est d'arriver au pouvoir
c'est
si la stratégie du rassemblement sionnel
fonctionner par coups de boutoir on a
déjà eu deux accession au second tour
avec un gain de voix phénoménale entre
2017 et 2022 là on a si on prend
législatives on part de qu'une poignée
de députés même pas de quoi faire un
groupe à 89 voilà si on trace une courbe
en effet la prochaine étape c est ce que
ce sera le coup de boutoir finale qui
permettra de 2,2 d'enfoncer la porte
c'est ce que ça dessine mais après on y
lit à 50,10 politique bien sûr bien sûr
que c'est l'union des droites hier soir
c'était très intéressant de voir que
marine le pen a dit la recomposition
politique n'est pas achevé c'est à dire
qu'en fait elle est en train de
reprendre à son compte la proposition
d'eric zemmour me dire on va rassembler
les droite
souverainiste nationaliste et caetera et
c'est ça qu'elle a proposé hier soir et
qu'elle est en train d'essayer de faire
et ce coup de boutoir qui vient d'être
passée laurent possible on a déjà vu des
gens d éminents dirigeants de l air
annoncé leur possible vote en faveur
d'eric zemmour ou de marine le pen
désormais qu mathieu en a on a commencé
par emmanuel macron on peut boucler sur
quand même parler de claques de j de
reprendre toutes les expressions de nos
confrères mais dans l'échec des manèges
macron il ya aussi l'échec de
l'affaiblissement des extrêmes
la promesse dans la willys pour deux
extrêmes qui était même sa promesse de
2006 16,7
oui oui alors après ccc on va pas lui
jeter la pierre à lui tout se sait pas
le seul responsable est évidemment que
c'est parce que je voulais dire et de
même façon et je partage tout à fait
l'avis de catherine tricot sur le fait
qu'en désignant la nuque comme cible
unique de le
pouvoir a détourné le regard d'une
certaine façon mais de la même façon la
nuque on n'a pas j'ai entendu beaucoup à
la fois pendant la campagne
présidentielle jean luc mélenchon s'en
prendre à marine le pen est à la fois
pendant cette campagne législative la
nuque hagist et le spectre d'une
possible entrée en force du
rassemblement national dans l'hémicycle
parce que ça ne les intéressait pas le
seul duel de ce2 ce2 sept de ces
législatives c'était un duel mélenchon
macron et donc c'est 2 à 2 2 bornes en
gros qui n'ont pas vu arriver
le rassemblement national au palais
bourbon après oui c'est un échec
personnel pour emmanuel macron qui se
targuait de vouloir recomposer le
paysage politique il ya un moment où ça
l'arrangé et 10è mois au centre et les
extrêmes parce qu'ils n'en ont jamais
une majorité sociologique et donc je
suis assuré moi et mon camp de conserver
le pouvoir estime est il ce pari là on
voit bien que il a pris un coup dans
l'ailé parce que la majorité
sociologique
leur assemblée nationale c'est vrai
était deux fois de suite au 2e tour et
en présentiel il entre avec la première
force d'opposition au parlement est la
prochaine étape ça ne paraît plus un
pouce qui était forte improbable ne
paraît plus fin possible en démocratie
ça dure jamais milan quand même le
pouvoir ce que je veux dire c'est que le
problème c'est que là on voulait des
disqualifiés la gauche et en l'appelant
les extrêmes regarder autour de la table
on nous appelle les extrêmes enfin je
veux dire pauvre pour vous des efforts
quoique se retrouvent dans les extrêmes
mais même mais même jean luc mélenchon à
d'autres socialistes qui l'on reprochait
d'avoir basculé
la radicalité d'extraits mais ne s'est
pas tout à fait la même chose ça peut
passer à la radio personnes système
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on a
on a du coup j'en ai perdu le fil ce que
je veux dire oui c'est ça t3 à
disqualifier en les appelant les
extrêmes en les rejetant et donc du coup
on est le modèle le cercle de la raison
comme étant la seule possibilité donc
mais ça ça ne marche pas ça ne marche
qu'un temps il ya forcément une
alternative qui va émerger le problème
c'est que là elle émerge d'une façon
très inquiétante merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat
catherine on va voir la une du dernier
numéro 2 de regards qui avait été publié
juste avant le second tour cet espoir de
victoire des gauches nul ça peut le
faire bon bah finalement ça ne l'a pas
tous à la faf et voilà est quand même
très loin de là la majorité
à l'assemblée et puis je rappelle le
titre de votre livre frédéric potier ce
thriller politique la menace 732 on est
aux éditions de l'aube a les joues